liebe freunde des gepflegten nach fläche
ich glaube den wendet er beim fragen
lotto mit weit die haben nicht nur das
ihr zeugen eines profunden wutausbruchs
von phil wertet nein wir spekulieren
auch darüber wie word wide täter wohl in
30 jahren heißen ihr könnt eure fantasie
schon mal freien lauf lassen und wir
spekulieren gleich darüber außerdem
fragen wir wann haben die jungs endlich
erfolg wobei ich kann mir vorstellen das
ist vielleicht schon ganz nah denn wenn
ihr alle standard time gedownloadet habt
dann sind die jungs in den charts also
drückt die daumen dass es klappt und
guckt das fragen lotto und abonnieren
damit er nichts was vom bc und ich sag
nur bis dann bleibt dran
ihr kennt es das frank otto und wie
immer haben wir
stundenlang darüber gegrübelt wie wir
euch außer fassung bringen können so ihr
könnt jetzt nicht wenn der rote jeder
nimmt erstmal ne rote ja und glauben im
bekommen irgendwas nimmt drei freien in
die vollen mit
reihe nach der reihe nach
wollt ihr nicht mal witzige videos
machen
also auf jeden fall wir probieren das
mithin zu bekommen weil wir sind ja
schon ein recht ernstes team und machen
immer recht ernste themen ja und der wir
probieren mal mit sich zu sein also wir
geben unser bestes warten endlich
vielleicht mit ständer teil ständer dann
könnten wir diese könnte minimal ist ja
auch ein recht ernsthaft das thema aber
sehr wohl hier ist nicht mehr man
munkelt der hammer munkelt ja immer ist
immer so unter der gürtellinie also her
nicht witzig eigentlich nicht aber fast
fast so
kann man noch etwas hinzufügen da kann
man immer was hinzufügen aber dann
muss muss nicht also ja nicht bei jürgen
krebs nehmen das machen wir nochmal sind
so viel gerne witzig mal genau video
genau
jemand aufdrehen ja genau links und
rechts aufdrehen
da gibt es uns drauf sagt
rink fest
was trägt man man man fragt uns als
bayern ob wir trinkfest sind es ist
natürlich eine vorlage kommt christoph
auf diese frage gebe ich als gebürtiger
franke keine antwort ich bin mir gar
kein kann ich gebürtig franke ich bin
aber seit ich denken kann lebe ich in
franken und darum bin ich natürlich
trinkfest ok sehr gut
das ist ja so eine komische für das
freut mich dann haben wir uns getroffen
ich glaube ich lasse es lieber so vor
wer von euch dreien ist das süßeste
ich sollte beantworten verwehrt von uns
dreien das süßeste ist ja könnt ihr das
nicht
so sagst du nicht wird es ist das ja
warum kannst du das nicht sagen hier ist
holz hacken ja ich bin ich bin ich ich
stelle die fragen an beantwortung ist
ihr das ist genau der punkt du stellst
die fragen hier machst
wirst du den leuten da draußen irgendwas
mit nein mir das ist unser moment
gekommen nur eine rote fragen kannst
bleibt alles drin du hast ein schönes
hemd übrigens ist gefällt mir als road
car ja so wollen natürlich auch einfach
open carol jetzt sind mal rote ihr seht
ihr die grünen habe ich ja schon gut
jetzt jahr hat ich sinnlos
ja das schauen wir später noch einmal
mehr dass aufwand geld
ach herrlich wer hat den letzten sketch
geschrieben
du also
wann habt ihr endlich erfolg
ja das frage ich mich jeden tag auch
wieder wenn ich aufwache unter der
bahnhofbrücke in deutsch
zur arbeit gehen die andere bahnhof
sorry die mama zusammen gemeinschaftlich
später ok als gut wieder
das ist eingeschnappt
wann geht ihr endlich mal auf die
schauspielschule
ist eine ernsthafte frage
ach stimmt du warst ja mal auf so was
ähnliches ich glaube das war doch schon
mal was gesagt hat
es ist ernster als
es ernst
meint es ernst oder ach ja ich weiß
ernst praxis noch mal erreichen die den
arsch auf youtube und das schon seit
fünf jahren und fragt sich ob mich
jemand auf der schauspielschule war
nie war ich nicht
und habe ich auch nicht vor ehrlich
gesagt wir haben davor einzubrechen ja
zu einem anderen menschen zu machen als
der der man ist und da ich keinen bock
drauf ok letzte rote und dann zum
abschluss der grüne und das immer durch
ich sehe schon irgendwie wie steht denn
die kommt ist also ich kann mir denken
da steht drin ist ja auf den namen city
gekommen nein das war ganz ehrlich die
böse frage wer weiß
naja das hat was mit namen zu tun
punkt punkt punkt was für ein blöder
name rund 30 jahren auch noch so heißen
wir hatten das auch mal weiter
gesprochen aber das gab ist nicht die
kamera tauglich wie der name oder in den
30 jahren heißen könnte
doch das auch jetzt nicht also ich kann
die ganz ehrlich beantworten die sich
aber mal
kommen
ja
okay jetzt die welt zu kommen feature
mit dem hamburger hängen
jetzt gelesen was macht euch mehr spaß
song parodien oder cowboys videos komme
die videos also was macht mehr spaß an
proteinen oder comedy videos ist auch
ihre fiese
eigentlich sollten ja die song parodien
auch gleichzeitig komme die videos seien
ja stimmt
ich sage jetzt einfach mal komme die
videos sind sketche
was uns da mehr spaß macht also es gibt
so paar ideen wie zum beispiel damals
besser gewesen das hat uns einfach
richtig viel spaß gemacht weil das ist
genau unser humor dieses ab geste sage
ich mal aber auch die song parodien sind
echt cool also new york safari zeit und
alles was dieses thema fanden wir dann
irgendwie selbst auch richtig cool und
hat noch richtig bock drauf also man
kann es wieder mal nicht sagen was da
mehr spaß macht das ist beides sehr cool
und so ein paradies sollten eigentlich
auch comedy video sei okay
weil die grünen ja
schlusswort zum schluss würde ich noch
mal ganz gerne ein bisschen eine kleine
dankesrede halten wir müssen uns
wirklich nochmal aufrichtig bedanken für
alles was passiert das in den letzten
fünf jahren christoph
stellen dateien vierzehnter zehnter auf
itunes amazon holt euch das ding
dann kann euch ja natürlich